ça ça vous fait rire ou pas Michel müer
il va engrosser une princesse et c'est
vous non moi j'ai pas dit non j'ai pas
dit oui je veux
dis le
lapsusient Claire Castillon bonsoir vous
venez d'écrire le grenier vous êtes
écrivain alors vous avez l'air vous
toutes timide et pourtant vous écrivez
des choses absolument effroyables que
peut-être aucun homme même n'oserait
écrire est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'écrire comme un homme non non pas pas
comme un homme comme comme j'avais envie
d'écrire comme j'avais besoin d'écrire
et comme c'est sorti tel quel par
provoque non pas par provoque par par
naturel par naturel je vais résumer
c'est c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui est amoureuse d'un homme marié c'est
l'istoire d'un adultère d'ailleurs qui
qui se finit bien puisqu'il y a un
enfant et cetera mais pendant tout le
temps de cette de cette relation avec
cet homme cette femme dit des choses
épouvantables en en permanence he elle
voudrait que son épouse soit violet
enfin bon et à chaque à chaque phrase
c'est vrai que c'est c'est très cru ou
il y a cette histoire d'adultère et puis
il y a l'histoire du du rejet du corps
donc c'est ce qui permet de parler du
corps mais on verra oui oui mais donc
vous le grenier c'est en même temps
c'est l'estomac et le sexe de la
narratrice et le cerveau et le cerveau
l'espace intérieur vraiment la enfin
l'intérieur de la poche complète alors
quand vous l'expliquez comme ça ça
semble très c'est très intellectualisé
le mieux peut-être c'est que vous lisiez
le début de votre livre oui tu pars il
est mais tu pars je n'ai que ton
dans mon grenier qui se mélange avec la
barbe à papa que je mange en entier
parce que dans les greniers il faut des
toiles d'araignées et aussi des bâtons
pour parfois décrocher l'étoile et ton
est pris au piège de l'araignée
et j'ai mal dans mon ventre et ma tête
est serrée tu me manques j'ai avalé ta
photo j'ai bu ton sental j'ai léché la
baignoire où tu avais pris ton bain
voilà et la suiteon c'est bien c'est bon
et moi qui tu vas faire un film faut le
faire non mais ce qu'on ne dit pas
làdedans c'est que tous les gens qui
sont ici ils ne pensent qu'au cul ils
travaillent pour le cul ils gagnent de
l'argent pour le cul parce que ça
intéresse tout le
monde alors monsieur est intéressé par
le C et même le curé est intéressé par
le C parce que parce que pourquoi il y a
tellement de pédophile parce qu'on on
interdit au prêtres de baiser c'est pas
normal les pasteurs baisent les rabins
baisent et eux ne baisent pas moi je me
suis attaqué à l'église uniquement parce
que il y a un prêtre quand j'avais 9 ans
qui m'a foutu la main à la on parle
encore de mais je veux dire alors à
partir de là les enfant aujourd'hui
combien ont-ils n'os pas parler c'est ça
qui grave la provocation c'est de faire
des films pour expliquer tout ça pour
expliquer pourquoi la vache est folle
pourquoi les curés sont pédophiles
pourquoi attendez curés son pédophil pas
tous à cause de la vache
fol non mais attendez dans tous les
métiers il y a des pédophiles oui mais
pas des gens qui qui qui prêchent la
religion qui prêchent l'abstinence qui
prêchent le C mène le monde le C
regardez Clinton avec sa bonne femme
regardez tout le monde regardez miterran
regardez tout ce qu'ils ont fait oh mais
Giscard destin toute la bande et Madame
de Breuil qu'est-ce qu'elle fait madame
de Breuil alors justement Marie blanche
de Breuil quand vous entendez g pierre
mi ça ça fait des années qu'il le dit on
l'a toujours entendu dire le cul mène le
monde c'est un constat c'est un constat
c'est un constat vrai constat bah ça ça
ça existe depuis depuis depuis que le
monde est monde que le monde des monde
mais on est là justement pour réprimer
ENF jeuse le cul pour réprimer ses ses
instincts moi je suis pas pour là pour
pour parler de de la séance on m'a dit
je veux pas avoir l'air d'un dipl de
cuch ou d'un dinosaure l'éducation c'est
justement
pour réprimer ses instincts voilà c'est
bien pour ça que je n'aime pas cette
idée d'éducation qui n'est qu'un
dressage c'est pas comme ça qu'on rend
les gens heut sair certainement mais en
c'est une question de de enfin vous
voulez parler non je voudrais juste
redonner oh c'est gentil Jean-Pierre Mo
je voudrais juste redonner la parole à
Castillon qui temps mais elle aussi elle
aime ça tout le me de lire l'extrait de
son livre elle n'a pas pu en bien savoir
ce qui se passe dans le grenier ça vous
lirez hein vous lirez je voudrais savoir
quand vous avez écrit ça clair alors
c'était il y avait de la provocation ou
pas parce que c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas
une seule page on ne parle pas de vomi
de constipation de
c'était pas c'était pas de la
provocation c'était c'était une espèce
de d'instinct de de survie parce que ça
fait tellement mal que parfois il arrive
de rire tellement c'est douloureux à
voir donc on peut enchaîner le rire les
larmes les tous ces états là et dans ce
livre là c'était parler des tripes avec
des mots tripales et tous ces motsl
c'est vrai que c'est c'est des mots
naturels je pouvais pas me faire une
fleur à chaque fois mais c'est un peu
comme une aussi une petite fille qui
dirait pipi caca boudin avec d'autres
mots c'est un peu comme si tout ça était
je suis d'accord c'est vrai que c'est ça
peut être ressenti comme ça et et c'est
normal parce que elle justement elle
reprend sa voix de petite fille pour
parler de pour parler de ce corps pour
parler de ce grenier qu'elle s'est forer
ça mais vous avez choqué autour de vous
étonné parce que c'est vrai que je je
parle pas comme ça et que c'est ce que
je laisse à l'écrit parce que je le
alors comment les hommes ont réagi à
votre livre il y a eu
des je pense que les hommes ont mieux
compris que les femmes
finalement ils ont ils ont mieux compris
souvent tout et souvent ils s'attachent
à des choses qui sont pas forcément
sexuelles et qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus intimes beaucoup plus qui
touch pas qui touchent pas justement au
corps ils sont allés chercher le reste
peut-être parce que cor choqué c'est ça
vous êain deoui ouis les femmes étaient
plus étaient plus dur avec le langage
est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui un
phénomène de mode parce qu'on a il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes jeunes
écrivaines moi je vais le dire au
féminin qui écrivent de plus en plus
justement sur la sexualité des histoires
de d'amour de
sexe de façon très cruetion sexuelle
elle est portée par des femmes qui
demandent en gros ce qu'on les a demandé
depuis longtemps mais est-ce que c'est
un phénomène de mode est-ce que c'est
par provoque ou c'est simplement parce
que tout simplement ça vend et on vend
bien mon avis c'est pas à mon avis c'est
pas par
provoque avant il y avait une Saré
censure aussi hein il y avait une
censure terrible pour le livre Régine de
forge et tout ça et pour ouvert et toute
la bande ils sont payés cher de en
diffusant des des des des vivre comme
comme elle pense à tonberê T au pilon
hein Christophe Lambert alors en tant
que publicitaire qui c'est vraiment le
rôle de la de la provocation dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et même au niveau
du cul c'est de faire en sorte que on
ouvre de temps en temps le couvercle
pour éviter que ça explose et c'était le
cas des maisons closuses et c'est le cas
de la littérature érotique et cetera
mais la provocation est un moyen elle
devient gratuite quand ça devient une
finalité c'est un moyen à un moment
donné d'aller faire avancer d'aller
lutter contre des blocages des interdits
et ça a une vraie fonction le mariage de
de luron et Coluche c'est c'est le
premier ça a abouti au Pax donc ça a une
vraie fonction ce qui dit en ce moment
c'est qu'on essaie de dissocier
simplement ça se voit dansain dans cette
littérature partout c'est qu'on veut
dissocier les sentiments de la baisse je
veux dire on peut bais sans amour et on
peut baiser avec amour et que les choses
sont là là attendez là je viens je une
seconde une seconde c'est parce que là
vous n'avez pas lu le livre là c'est
l'amour à mort c'est l'amour à mort donc
je te donne mes tripes à manger c'est
pas c'est
pas Baour c'estàdire que c'est au nom de
l'amour pour résumer son livre au nom de
l'amour tout est possible tout peut se
dire tout peut se penser tout peut se
faire liberté tout peut se dire tout
peut se penser maintenant se faire ou
pas dans la limite d'autrui mais enfin
nom de Dieu je dis on n pas eu le siècle
des Lumières pour retomber là-dedans on
peut tout penser n'importe quelle
pratique sexuelle est pensable et il
faut arrêter de ne pas pouvoir en parler
tout la zoophilie tout est pensable
maintenant que la société légifère ça
c'est une autre chose et nous sommes là
pour est- est-ce que tout peut se dire
non moi je dis
que tout peut
penser tout tout peut se penser que tout
peut se dire peut sénoncer très strict
avec soi-même et très tolérant vis-à-vis
des autres ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que pour soi-même on a son son mode
de vie son idéal son mais vis vis-à-vis
des autes vis-à-vis des autres il faut
savoir les écouter les comprendre
pourquoi ce qu'ils font si ou ça et pas
être braqué quelque fois non mais si
vous avez des pulsions elles sont là et
vous réfléchissez pas vous y allez vous
avez des pulsions
allez-yzy j'aimerais peut-être qu'on
fasse un un tout petit peu un point avec
Maester alors il faut que je lise c'est
moi oui lisez parce que nous le jour où
les prêtres ressembleront à Lio l'église
gagnera des
fidèle ça ça c'est gentil non mais ça
c'est ça c'est pas très provoque quand
même si c'est provoque pas vis-à-vis de
moi mais vis-à-vis de Monsieur R du tout
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
provoque tout moi je connais des
dizaines de cheft qui sont exactement
comme lo ça m'étonnerait et arrêtez tout
de suite parce que on va aller
s'expliquer dehors je refuse présente ah
ça alors Michel müer fallait pas
l'inviter il va engrosser une princesse
ça
alors ça c'est ça c'est pour vous Marie
j'essaie j'essaie d'attaquer doucement
non non vous inquiétez pas Mar je va
vous expliquer expliqu après d'accord
que jeis vous emmener au club juste
après dans un petit club tous les
deuxchangiste ça ça vous fait rire ou
pas si si c'est vous Marie
blanche je vois pas ce qu' est auudessus
vous inqutez lui montrez pas ne lui
montrez pas il me dis Pasir alors mich
il va engosser une princesse et c'est
vous moi j'ai pas dit non j'ai pas dit
oui je ve
dire bravo
MZ au travail aller tout de suite je
suis bien chaud moi j'ais bien on a 5
minutes ou vousz où vous j' bien que la
princesse alors je voudrais quand même
demander Lio
depuis l'époque de Banana Split vous
aviez 14 ans oui j'avais 14 ans quand
j'ai commencé 16 ans quandque est sorti
oui voilà
aujourd'huien 38 38 mère de 5 enfants
tris pères différents ah oui c'est une
merre la pile on est déjà
Surp il existe des pilules vous vous
avez toujours parlé ouvertement de de de
sexualité je disais simplement parce que
vous vous sentez une femme libérée au
départ vous l'avez fait vraiment pour
provoquer quand on a un fort él de vie
c'est forcément provocateur parce que la
société va à l'inverse donc voilà al
attendez lo je t'aime on fait le 6e
c'est une déclaration d'amour deaccord
je suis
d'accord quand les journalistes
écrivaient HE sont des phrases que j'ai
prises dans la presse des critiques
sévères à votre égard c'est une imbécile
qui fait la conne on a écrit sur vous
des trucs terribles c'est physique de
concierge et puis j'en passe et des
meilleurs que vous montriez votre cul
pour faire du blé pas JAL mais je sais
pas dans V lectur ou oui non mais on est
allé chercher ce qu'on dit les elle le
sait les journalistes de lot à un moment
donné est-ce que est-ce que ça vous
ennuyait ça vous donnait envie de au
contraire d'en rajouter vous êtes dit
ils n'ont rien compris ou à un moment
donné vous êtes dit je suis allé trop
loin non forcément j'ai réfléchi à à
pourquoi tout ça mais parce que je suis
dans le jeu social et politique donc
forcément ça m'intéresse c'est amusant
aussi mais non je me suis jamais dit que
j'étais allé trop loin je me suis
toujours dit que je n'étais jamais allé
assez loin et pas avec assez de talent
surtout pourquoi vous aimez vous
finalement vous mettre à nu et parler de
votre intimité de de la rendre publique
c'est pas comme ça que je pose question
justement je je dis que je me suis que
j'ai commencé très très jeune à 16 ans à
être une personne public fort mise en
question et que j'ai grandi sous l'œil
des des caméras c'est je suis venue
petite fille leolita jusqu'à une femme
et et j'ai vécu ma vie de femme et ma
vie de citoyenne et je n'ai jamais su
faire un réel
cassure entre les deux parce que ça pour
moi ça a toujours été mêlé et j'essaie
toujours de mieux m'amuser de mieux
comprendre et et de de mieux me placer
j'aime bien l'art du combat je trouve
que tout ça et quand on dit l'art du
combat c'est pas aimer la guerre c'est
c'est un art de se placer c'est quand
même un jeu j'ai quand même fortement
l'impression d'un grand jeu dans cette
vie et voilà j'aime bien jouer
Jean-Pierre Moki vous ne dites rien
alors qu'est-ce que vous pensez de lo
qu'est-ce que vous pensez là de ce que
dit lo bah vous savez les les stars qui
ont commencé très jeunes comme Vanessa
Paradis lo elles ont une vie un peu
particulière quand même elle est libre
depuis l'âge de 14 ans et voilà et c'est
une femme libre qui a fait 5in enfants
c'est tout à fait bien mais je pense pas
qu'elle représente le le télect la
téléspectatrice habituelle c'est une
exception en quelque sorte et je pense
que il faut des femmes comme ça et cette
femme-là aussi cette jeune femme elle
moi je trouve que c'est bien d'avoir
invité des gens qui sont différents
parce que bon madame madame n'est pas
différente elle elle a une on la voit on
envoie des dames comme ça ça c'est un
peu plus particulier donc on est
intéressé de savoir qu'il existe permett
alors l'une et l'autre elle permett de
faire existe churon existe C phiqueclair
Castillon permett de non mais on
pourrait l'engager vous allez l'engager
non mais il est il est virile là je
vachement virile alors donc Jean-Pierre
mqu est-ce que Lio Claire Castillon
Castillon pardon permettent de de faire
film c'est des hroes non mais de faire
progresser le le les choses les
mentalités par rapport au f oui parce
queé n'écrivait pas ça comprz alors donc
elle n'écrivait pas ça et même François
Sagan n'écrivait pas ça c'était beaucoup
plus tempér donc là on arrive quelque à
quelque chose dans est l'an 2000 et on a
une un écrivain comme ça et on a une
actrice qui qui a C enfants mais qui dit
je vais baiser avec le monsieur Lab
c'est quand même quelque chose ça vous
disiez que personne n'arrivera à vous
rendre décente alors pourquoi vous avez
dit ça et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'ailleurs en fait je suis je n'aime pas
l'autorité c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui me hérisse l'autorité me me fait
chier je trouve qu'elle est toujours
usurpée d'une certaine manière donc
voilà oui je ne voudrais pas être
descente je ne voudrais pas rentrer dans
un dans un consensus je suis si vous
voulez vigilante là-dessus non pas pour
des raisons purement moralistes et
chiantes mais parce queussi ça m'amuse
et que c'est ma vie j'essaie de
m'appartenir sans cesse Marie blanche de
BR j'ai envie de dire princesse Marie
très conventionnel est-ce que vous vous
allez lire déjà le livre de de CL
certainement parce qu'elle est très
sympathique certainement ce que dit lo
vous amuse vous choque est-ce que vous
pensez que justement c'est une femme
libre oui est-ce que vous l'vier alors
ah moi je suis très heureuse dans ma vie
alors je je suis très heureuse de la vie
que je l'ai mais je l'admire beaucoup
parce
que j'admire parce qu'elle a du talent
parce que nous on nous a toujours dit ne
vous mettez pas en avant juste le juste
le le contraire tis que de voir une
femme jeune comme ça qui a le courage de
toutes ses opinions moi je trouve ça
merveilleux donc dans tout ce qu'elle
dit rien ne vous choque finalement alors
tout ce qu'elle dit ou ce qu'elle ce
qu'elle
montre je ne sais pas si je garderai
tout pour ma pour ma vie privée à moi
mais tout ce qu'elle fait elle
m'intéresse parce que il faut quand même
un certain courage aussi vous êtes en
train de changer de camps hein est ah
non non je change pas de
camp ce soir elle va SAU sa tête la
princesse faites
le et et et les propos quand même de du
professeur churon ou de Jean-Pierre Moky
alors les hommes par rapport aux hommes
est-ce que vous avez la même indulgence
et tolérance ou pas sincèrement he
sincèrement m'a dit que j'étais banale
alors banale vous lui avez dit banale
physiquement banal dans sa vie ah dans
VI oui en c'est la vie oui excusez-moi
donc là vous
êtes Prine le problème c'est que votre
vie semble plus banale que celle de ou
celle de la demoiselle dirais pas banale
mais je dirais plus conforme à ce qu'on
attend oui vous êtes une femme comme il
faut merci beaucou voilà et alors nous
on est des gens comme il faut pas
rapport à
vous donc on y arrive tout est
reltif
est Madame bovar par ex bien les femmes
comme il faut aussi Jean-Pierre me mais
ça dépend pour quoi fait non mais non je
dire les femmes comme il
faut comme le professeur chon pardon je
dis ell peuvent exciter des gens comme
le professeur ch je pense pourquoi vous
dites ça que il disait rien depuis 5
minutes
Prine moi j'aurais aimé j'aurais aimére
princesse je dire on m'aura donné à
choisir en sortant des testicules de
papa en disant est-ce que tu veux nître
chez le prince ou est-ce que tu veux
nître dans le caniv j'aurais préféré
aller chez Prin et en plus je t'avoue
que j'ai jamais sauté une princesse dans
ma vie ça oh
arrêtez pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Inna mire Guma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche